[Music]
it's an Irish family that you come from
Irish descent it is it the classic Irish
Catholic family where you don't talk
about certain things is there another
kind I know that's kind of the world I
grew up for example no one wouldn't you
don't sit around an Irish Catholic
family and talk about sex because it
doesn't exist right right we just
materialize Mary Mary's all about yeah
three three Catholics were like that's
not funny Victor's don't so awkward for
you growing up it's you know I was not
I've very sweet parents good parents I'm
like we didn't see racy movies I was I
was a little sheltered and I I remember
being at a slumber party and I want to
say like fourths fourth grade or some
some fourth fifth grade kind of and
somehow something kind of about like sex
came up and I was like yeah that's for
sure
I had no idea and then somehow questions
and I think everybody knew I was being
pretty like strange and I said well it
doesn't matter my parents don't they
don't do that anyway they've never done
it and everyone just says everyone kind
of stopped and they were like what what
do you think it is I was like they just
haven't done it I know what it I know
what it is they just have they don't do
that no more have they ever or are they
going to do it they kept grilling me I
was like let's just go back to listen to
Rick Rick Springfield and they don't
want to do that and ice my theory was
and I made a big Proclamation I said I
know they've never done it because my my
I know for a fact my dad can't do the
Chinese splits what and that's what I
was like I know my dad can't do the
Chinese split so they've never had sex
okay can I ask you what are the Chinese
splits Chinese splits like you can go
right left and when both legs go out yes
it's like gymnast conductor like the
Chinese we from the from watching the
Olympics that stuff we we always call it
middle splits Chinese foots right so
it's like one way completely out the
other clearly you thought that one had
be able to do that in order to have sex
I did not know hearts moved so I assumed
both parties watch the show I literally
thought that you had to go like that and
then I guess you laid down it excluded
him sure I'm sure do that next to each
other once you're in that position you
know dollies and when I said that I was
so I was teased for a very very long
time yeah
very long time yeah I just didn't know
like there was no race oh I'm sure it
wouldn't actually it would be great if
both people could do that but I think I
also kind of said it like duh
[Laughter]
you